so earlier this season in january i
believe at golden state you completed
the nba arena tour
you've been everywhere how was it it was
amazing yeah i i can't believe it like
to see the pistons play in every single
nba arena plus las vegas plus mexico
city a couple years ago
unreal it was it was an incredible time
when did you come up with this idea when
i was a kid is something i dreamt of
doing and a few years ago i just went to
milwaukee in chicago and indiana and it
just sort of spiraled from there yeah so
you're a piston season ticket holder
today they hooked you up you're sitting
court size big time it's incredible it's
a lifelong dream to sit courtside i i
honestly i can't believe it like i'm
still in disbelief that it's it's
happening like it's it's insane to be
this close now we just pulled you away
from the court side cease to talk to me
all right we'll let you get back to it
brother all right thank you i appreciate
it
all right corey nicholas love it hey
jordan
george will you join me in tipping our
hat to that fan oh corey yeah i'm proud
of you we appreciate your support you're
loyal he seems like a great guy yeah
that's awesome
mexico city when he said that we both
looked at each other yeah well we
said are we in mexico city yes we are